it's taken
50 years for this victory to come but
after being wrongfully sent to prisoners
teenagers their lives ruined as a result
paul greene and cleveland davidson have
finally had their names cleared
i haven't been the same my family didn't
believe me no one believed me
because they think oh you know you you
you must have done something you know so
my mom and
my mum and father died and up to that
day my dad did not believe me it was
detective sergeant derek ridgwell who
was believed
a corrupt officer who accused the men of
trying to rob him on the london
underground in 1972
they had been on a night out with their
friend courtney harriet who's also been
cleared and three others
they became known as the stockwell six
after a trial at the old bailey
one was acquitted five convicted
cleveland davidson was sentenced to six
months in prison while paul greene
17 at the time was sent to borsal young
offenders center
something he only told his children
about this year
i was sad that he didn't feel like he
could share that with us you know
it must have been so hard carrying that
it was very
yeah it was very hard yeah it's all
right
it's all right but it's gone now it's
gone yeah it's
gone i know i can hold my head up high
in quashing these convictions the lord
chief justice lord burnett
said there was now an accumulating body
of evidence that pointed
to the unreliability of evidence given
by d s ridgewell
and others in this specialist group it
means
there could be dozens of other people
who have also been wrongfully convicted
three of ridgewell's cases have now seen
convictions overturned
the oval four is another the corrupt
officer was eventually sent to prison
himself
where he died in 1982. woodrow threw a
hand grenade into my
life and blew it up blew it up smashed
to pieces
winston true spent decades fighting to
clear their names
before it finally happened in 2019. they
should conduct a
thorough investigation follow through
into all of brazil's corruption
and see how he basically corrupted the
whole
the whole policing system first though
fresh attempts will now be made to
contact the remaining two members of the
stockwell six
so they too can experience justice iva
bennett
sky news at the court of appeal